ja ich glaube dass und das leider schon
länger dass wir deutschland ganz
grundsätzlich reformieren müssen und wir
brauchen nicht nur ein
beschleunigungsgesetz in einzelnen
fällen wie jetzt für den klimaschutz
sondern wir brauchen eine ganz
grundsätzliche neuorientierung
wir sind zu langsam wir haben viel zu
viele auf geteilten zuständigkeiten
zwischen kommunen ländern bund und
europa ist viel zu viel um geklärt
werden keine entscheidungsgremien wenn
wir das nicht endlich hinbekommen wenn
wir viele umbau ziele nicht hinbekommen
namentlich nicht die beschaffung zum
beispiel bei der bundeswehr weil wir das
gerade hatten aber wir haben es auch in
corona gesehen sommers ist in 50 prozent
der gesundheitsämter nach zwei jahren
pandemie immer noch nicht eingeführt
wir werden das den klimawandel so nicht
bewältigt bekommen und ich bin
eigentlich sehr traurig dass die ampel
zwar dieses ziel ausgegeben hat sowie
die cdu ist aufgefordert hat nur leider
die maßnahmen weggelassen hat deswegen
das ziel nicht erreichen kann
wären wir schon gerade gefragt während
des statements ob sie das war ja sie
dürfen sich natürlich direkt jetzt
jemand ich kann es kann sie nicht
ersparen das ist ja alles richtig was
sie sagen und ich habe da sehr viele
sympathien für aber auf einer anderen
seite wer hat letzten 16 jahre dieses
land regiert wer hat in der korona
pandemie letztlich bundeswehr ist das
andere thema hier oder wer steht dafür
dass dieses land stück weit an die wand
gefahren wurde dass wir genau gucken
müssen wie wir die zukunftsfähigkeit des
landes der verwaltung im bereich
digitalisierung all den anderen
bereichen hinbekommen das ist die union
und deswegen ist es schön wenn sie jetzt
sagen dass dass sie das auch so sehen
das haben sie das gebe ich ihnen zu
letzten jahren auch immer schon getan
aber auf der anderen seite sind die drei
ampel parteien jetzt seit 126 tagen in
der verantwortung sie hatten 16 jahre
zeit wir haben einen krieg wir haben
eine pandemie die noch ausläuft geben
sie uns ein bisschen zeit die vorhaben
planung zumindest soweit auf den weg ich
werde das sie sehen könnt erkennen
können dass wir die probleme die werden
koalitionsvertrag angerissen haben auch
anfangen denn uns also der c 3
kommentare es ist eine gemeinsame schuld
natürlich auch der union werbe bei alle
länder und alle kommunen beteiligt sind
ist die fdp hat ja auch im boot sie
recht das heißt wir müssen eine
gesamtstaatlichen aufbruch machen die
union ist aber dann die erste gewesen
wäre neustadt gruppe zu der gruppe die
dann auch das zu einem schwerpunkt
gemacht hatten und gesagt wir müssen
alle auf jene union umkehren so und der
zweite ist ich werf ich natürlich
überhaupt nicht voran höchsten kitas
jetzt 120 tagen noch keine ergebnisse
haben das nicht mein punkt mein punkt
ist ein punkt ist dass sie alle
entscheidenden maßnahmen die wir nur am
anfang einer korrektur machen kann
auflösung des ressort prinzips
einführung des digitalen systems die fdp
habe ich auch gefordert hat aber dann
sind sie wieder an der spd genauso wie
wir gescheitert alle diese notwendigen
strukturellen veränderungen sind alle
nicht passiert und es gibt dieses schöne
bild im digital ausschuss von sitzen sie
mich drin wir haben ein wimmelbild
gemacht wenn man ganz ehrlich ist war
schon in der alten koalition
digitalem ein wimmelbild möglichkeiten
gemacht die ehrliche antwort ist das war
auch schon auf eine merkel schlimme so
und dann haben wir ein wimmelbild
daneben wie es jetzt ist das ist noch
schlimmer so es ist nicht besser und ich
schlimmer geworden daraufhin hatten ein
riesiges in wien ansässigen gesagt das
bild sei falsch er würde ein neues
liefern darauf warten wir jetzt schon
seit zwei monaten und die
zuständigkeiten zurückkehren
sie hat nicht mal die schulen die
zuständigkeiten hat die ampel geklärt
ist meine prognose die vier jahre werden
sie es nicht schaffen und das bedeutet
wohl jetzt einen schiedsrichter da rein
weil das dagegen sind es klar dass sie
dafür sind wie toll es ist auch klar
deswegen wollen wir jetzt in meinen
experten rhein selbst solar chef von
unserem parlamentsbüro bild wie
erfolgreich ist die ampel denn jetzt
bislang in den letzten tagen ja gut kurz
nach dem start kann man jetzt schwer
sagen wie der zieleinlauf wird sie haben
ja beide recht also ist über die ziele
über die ziele besteht ja gar kein gar
keinen dissenz glaube ich zwischen fdp
und auch zwischen den heilmann hat er
ein dickes buch herausgegeben neustadt
wo man von seite zu seite immer sagen ja
müsste kommen müsste kommen nur da sind
wir wieder bei der denkt wende in vielen
dieser
blockaden spielen ja verschiedenste
mitbestimmungsrechte der der bürger eine
rolle der verschiedenen kommunen bund
und länder blockieren sich gegenseitig
was hier aufzulösen ist ist eigentlich
so grundlegend in unserem in unserer
verfasstheit sie können nicht einfach
hingehen können einen amt digitalisieren
und da jetzt eine neue software
einführung da sagt die gewerkschaft ja
gut da brauchen wir jetzt erstmal
wochenlang schulungen für alle
mitarbeiter und wenn jetzt jemand mit
dem bohrer durchgeht und kabel verlegt
dann muss vorher ein neuer raum plan ist
es ist alles verrechnet und und so von
von mit bestimmungen durchsetzt aus
guten gründen immer nur um gerechtigkeit
zu schaffen und um alles auszutarieren
dass wir einfach blockiert sind und dass
aufzulösen das ist so wahnsinnig schwer
denn er steht ja dafür da höre ich es
mal anfangen die fdp hat früher immer
geworben für eine steuerreform beide
steuerrecht ist nun ziemlich kompliziert
was in deutschland gibt einfach niedrig
und gerecht hat man inzwischen auch
regieren lernen das hätten wir gerne mit
der union 2009 gemacht aber da war frau
merkel nicht dabei sind andere untersagt
wäre bestimmt dabei gewesen der selbst
er vorsitzt vielleicht gibt es ja ein
revival etwas einfaches wie die mehrheit
steuer vereinheitlichen das können sie
an den finanzminister mal vorschlagen er
weiß ganz genau dass er damit scheitern
wird weil die schnittblumen hersteller
ja man die tageszeitung brauchen
selbstverständlich ihren niedrigen
steuersatz das ist ja klar
wir haben
vertraglich vereinbart
haben wir im koalitionsvertrag ohne
maßnahmen wirklich endlich ja gerade wir
werden jetzt die nächsten tage hinzieht
niemals in den nächsten wochen wenn wir
in der ukraine ein bisschen eine
stabilere lage hoffentlich bald haben
werden uns wieder stärker auch um die
innenpolitik kümmern können ich bitte da
wirklich um verständnis auch gerade herr
wissing was die bahn momentan leistet in
letzten wochen geleistet hat aus
warschau nach berlin das sind alles
themen das erst mal genau hin wer bist
du gerade darüber zu dann wissen sie
aber auch der haben ja wirklich zu
allererst ein alleingang letzten monaten
aufgaben gehabt die uns quasi vom
tagesgeschäft abgehalten haben das ist
ja alles zustand mir geht es darum dass
die grundsatzbeschlüsse der ampel und
misst die die fdp auch in ihrem
wahlprogramm gefördert haben alle nicht
um mich nicht beschlossen wurde und dass
sie unter jährige jetzt in digitalen in
ihren reihen zu haben das werden wir
nicht tun aber warten sie doch
mal je mehr ist so rüber ja man merke
richtig wie gut das ist gut dass sie so
rüberbringen sind an der optimistische
töne eine optimistische partei das ist
schön aber natürlich ihr fazit brauchen
wir eine modernisierung brauchen wir
eine zeitenwende in der politik ja ich
glaube wir sehen ja jetzt sozusagen nach
16 jahren bundesregierung es gibt jetzt
ein aufbruch der sozusagen über die
ampel organisiert wird da sind ein paar
verkrustungen man ist auch vielleicht zu
satt gewesen am schluss in der union man
hat die letzten vier jahre vielleicht
auch nicht genutzt für viele reformen es
gibt reformstau in deutschland dazu gibt
es noch eine europäische bürokratie die
ohren top drauf kommt aber ich glaube es
ist ein mentalitätsproblem der deutschen
das ist kein regierungsprogramm es ist
kein sozusagen administratives problem
es ist ein mentalitätsproblem die fdp
hatte mal glaube ich digitalisierung
first bedenken second oder so was hatte
sie nur bedingt
digitalisierung first kommt aber das ist
ja ich will jetzt gar nicht mit dem
finger zeigt es ist ja ein großes
problem ich habe in den niederlanden
studiert und habe da eine
steuererklärung gemacht da habe ich mich
mit meiner digitalen bürger id
eingeloggt habe in eine suchmaske
irgendwas eingegeben paar zahlen und
damit war die erledigt wenn ich hier bei
elster reingehe ist das nicht
bürgerfreundlich ist es auch nicht
digital oder einfach es ist einfach nur
ein monstrum und da haben wir ganz viele
probleme in deutschland wir regulieren
uns zu tode und ich glaube man muss
diesen es geht die csu hat den ansatz
die fdp hat ihn auch von in mord als für
jedes neue gesetz eine andere
regulierung rausnehmen und dergleichen
ich glaube an das wird nicht gehen und
wir brauchen in radikalen ansatz und wir
müssen verkrustungen diesem land massiv
aufbrechen sonst sind wir irgendwann
nicht mehr da